[Music]
today we'll talk about accelerating IOT
fence serve and supply chain innovation
with Janice keV and BigTable my name is
Misha Brooklyn I'm a product manager on
Google cloud BigTable I'm also a
co-founder a member of the technical
steering committee for Janice graph and
open source distributed graph database
and with me today we have Ryan Hall from
exterior
Ryan my name is Brian Hall I'm with
Xperia consultancy we've been working
with graph databases and doing graft
projects for the better part of five
years we've been involved with the Janus
graph initiative since its inception and
one of our senior architects is a
co-founder with Misha on the on the
committee it's my hope today that when
you're done you you have a good
grounding in Janus graph and why you
might get excited and can pick a good
use case with which to deploy this
technology what we'll walk through today
is a little bit for about graph
databases for those of you that don't
don't know anything about them yet we'll
talk a little bit about why marrying
graph with time series data is a very
powerful paradigm we'll walk through how
that manifests itself in a few different
use cases in IOT financial services and
supply chain and then at the end
michio will walk you through how you
would actually make this happen on GCP
it's important to note that while while
what we're talking about here today is
reasonably new the mathematical
foundations upon which it's built had
been around for millennia the original
graph problem was
was solved by a Swiss mathematician in
the 1700s by by the name of Leonard
Euler and he solved a famous intractable
problem called the bridges of königsberg
by reducing it to what is now known as
modern graph theory it turns out that a
lot of the same things the same same
paradigms and concepts that he used to
solve this problem are also useful for
solving your tricky Sudoku puzzle as
well as determining the fewest a number
of moves to swap positions on a chess
board a little more tangibly what I
would all that there are several
real-world algorithms that can be put to
use clustering between this similarity
we all know what PageRank is good for I
would I would recommend that you look at
some of the the URLs at the end of the
slot at the end of the presentation
there are several great recipes on the
tinkerer pop website with graph
algorithms and and good use cases as to
as to when to use them graphs are graphs
are modeled in the real world all over
the place transportation networks can be
modeled as graphs computer networks and
IOT can be modeled as graphs the
canonical social network that we're all
familiar with can be modeled in a graph
interestingly the first commercial
database IBM's IMS modeled a graph as a
bill of materials in the late 60s for
the Saturn 5 project when we talk about
graph databases one flavor is known as
the RDF triple store stands for resource
description format coming out of
research around the Semantic Web in the
late 90s it consists of a three part
tuple with a subject predicate and
object in this case I've got Brian as a
person Misha is a person Brian knows
Misha these are all examples of RTS RDF
triples sparkle is the query language
and this is not what Janus graph is so
the second the second category of a
graph database is something called a
property graph
where you have both vertices and edges
each of them may have properties and
edges are directed while Sparkle is the
lingua franca for RDF triples
there are various query languages to be
used against property graphs Janus graph
is a property graph and the query
language that we use here is something
called ghrelin when we work with clients
all over the place we try to pick the
right use case and ask them is the graph
a good fit for this use case so usually
it consists of a couple different
questions are their natural networks in
my data and do I have to traverse the
graph in order to get the answers to the
questions I'm asking oftentimes we work
with clients and the answer to the first
question is yes and the answer to the
second question is no for instance in
the supply chain use case I might I
might think that graph would be a good
application if I for instance was
looking to see an outage and how it
might ripple through my supply chain but
conversely if I'm trying to figure out
what does the net sum total of widgets
in my suite of warehouses that's kind of
a classic a sequel use case so it's
always important to make sure that you
pick the right the right use cases and
the right problems when you deploy this
technology but when you do find the
right take when you do find the right
problem it can be a very concise and
elegant solution to the questions you're
asking this example here is a is a dirt
simple recommendation engine where on
the left you see a 14 table inner and
outer join and and on the right you see
a very concise Gremlin query this this
is actually built under the premise that
if you and I have nine of the same
products in common and I have the 10th
one you're likely to also want that 10th
one what we also find in many cases is
marrying a graph database with a time
series data can be a very powerful
paradigm what we end up modeling
frequently or atomic unit snapshots in
time where
capturing a stock price on a given day
or a reading on an IOT sensor and then
as I stack them together then I've got a
time series so this gives me the micro
view of what is happening at any given
point in time and how it trends over
time what when I marry that with a graph
what I can also do is get a bigger sense
of how these things are interrelated and
possibly understand causality why is
this thing trending up while the other
thing is trending down if I see either
either of them in on their own I don't I
don't have that context if I see it
modeled as a graph in conjunction with
the time series you know then I might be
able to understand the relations and
possibly even predict where things might
go in the future so how does this
manifest itself in in in use cases in
the real world
so for these use cases that we're going
to walk through one in one in each of
the industries will outline the problem
we'll walk through a little bit about
how you would model it in a property
graph we'll walk through the use case of
how we exploit this data model so that
you understand the process he involved
and then in a couple of examples we'll
walk through some user interfaces about
how this would manifest itself if you
were going to build a finished product
as a reminder all the things that you're
going to see here in a second these are
all property graph models with vertices
and edges and and each of them may have
may have properties edges are directed
some of these graphs are a little bit
busy so we've we've dropped some of the
properties just for clarity so how would
I do this in an IOT setting the this
model that I'm going to walk through is
is useful and can be kind of translated
in several different scenarios one would
be computer networks I could model this
as sensors in the oil and gas industry
industrial networks
power grids those sorts of things so
questions we might be able to answer and
these in this setting would be what
would this service what does this
service actually depend on you saw the
sto use cases earlier
at the keynote there's some similarities
to what you'll see here if if I'm trying
to find the shortest path between two
nodes in a network how would I would I
find that and then the one that we'll
walk through here is what is the impact
of a service outage in my SAS
application so imagine imagine I'm
modeling an infrastructure I've got a
SAS application and this SAS application
consists of a couple of web interfaces
and maybe an external API that my
clients are consuming each of these in
turn is reliant on internal api's and
those api's are reliant on other
internal API s at the end of the day
eventually I've got to get data from
somewhere and a couple of these api's
are querying a database and one of them
is query and search engine search index
so when the system is healthy
everybody's green but imagine I've got
some spike in the CPU on one of my
databases right I see a time series
getting woven into my graph model and
I've seen I see the CPU is spiked
clearly if that if that database spikes
then this API is going to be affected
the other upstream API will be affected
and then my web interfaces are going to
go out or be be in trouble so while this
might be a very obvious easy to eyeball
scenario in a 12 node Network imagine
this if you've got hundreds or even
thousands of services and how you know
how would I predict what's going to
happen based on some outage I might use
this information in order to deploy
limited extra resources maybe I've got
budget where's my biggest point of
failure where's my susceptibility or
where's my my anchor client gonna get
affected I might want to put whatever
extra budget I have toward making sure
that that one is bulletproof
here's a here's a mock-up generated by
us that walks through this use case you
see an elastic search a node that's
laboring and is affecting Janice graph
and a spring boot API going upstream you
see some tabular data on the right and
telling us a little bit about
what alarm has gone off and why and and
down at the bottom here on the next you
see some sort of a time a time frame I
might want to be zooming forward or back
maybe I can maybe I can rewind the clock
a little bit and figure out what was it
that happened last hour that caused my
elasticsearch node to to spike how might
I do this in supply chain so in supply
chain there are several several graphs
that can be modeled in this space you've
got the suppliers and how they how they
interoperate with each other you've got
the actual bill of materials that
they've finished good it consists of
some raw materials and some sub
components and subcomponents of sub
components
you've got transportation networks how
does this actually get from from factory
to shelf so questions that we like to
ask here are things like what would
happen if God forbid there was a
shipments if there's an earthquake here
today
where are my bottlenecks in my supplier
Network again trying to address extra
budget maybe I can do something to help
bulletproof my supply chain and then for
those of us from Texas what what what
finished products are affected when we
have a flood in Houston so here's a
contrived as a supplier network imagine
I've got some some cars that I'm
assembling and I've got engines and
cylinders I've got blocks assemblers and
finished products I've also got to build
a material in this case I've got an
engine that's kept that's composed of a
block and a head and inside of the block
I've got Pistons and cylinders if I put
the two together then what I see is each
of the the billa material that may flow
through my supply chain so turns out
here here's here's the time series again
it turns out each of these suppliers
that you know they they have inventory
on hand so I've got some I've got some
of my engines on on the shelf already
and then I want to I want to simulate
this disruption so imagine this
down at the bottom is in Houston
obviously he goes out the supply lane
actually gets affected as does that next
supplier this supplier here is affected
because as you see he's got no inventory
on hand in September right he cannot
weather the storm metaphorically this
other supplier he actually has some
inventory on hand so he can he's got
some capacity to continue to meet his
SLA
even after the flood you also see the
bottom supplier he's feeding into this
supplier so he's unaffected as well so
here you see again where the the time
series in the graph tells you more a
better view of the whole here's another
visual mock-up of supply chain
disruption simulator this is on our
website where you can actually geo code
and draw simulated outages based on your
on your supplier Network and simulate
the effects of simulate the effects of
an outage and how you might want to try
to reroute some of your supplies how
might we do this in a financial services
setting in financial services you see
graph identifying fraudulent activity
you can you can use the social network
model for criminal network detection and
then in this one we'll walk through
evaluating complex structured products
so imagine imagine how would I consider
valuing something that's not overly
obvious what the current value is so so
in the first two examples we were
talking through use cases that might be
consumed by finished product but in this
case imagine you've got a data scientist
who's testing some feces he's got he's
got lots of data some public some not so
public and he's trying to figure out you
know how do i how do i value something
based on all of these different data
sets that i might not be able to
assimilate just yet so in this case
we're going to value a REIT for those of
you don't know what a REIT is it's
essentially a real estate investment
trust and what that means is it's a big
basket of
state properties that you value in
totality so in our in our REIT we've got
two properties one property is a
shopping mall in Oklahoma and the other
one is a waterpark in Florida and we
noticed that the or we've been able to
model that the the shopping mall in
Oklahoma actually is is managed by
professional property manager and also
has two tenants that are in it we've got
some public data about the value of this
REIT and we see that it is trending up
and possibly what I've also got is some
not so public data where I've got a way
to capture foot traffic maybe this may
be this note at the bottom is a is my
anchor tenant and I've now been able to
determine that there's some correlation
between foot traffic in my anchor tenant
and the value of my publicly traded REIT
maybe maybe if I've tested enough feces
I'm confident enough in that that
hypothesis that I might be willing to
trade ahead of that information so
hopefully you've seen a couple of
different use cases and scenarios where
coupling the graph with the time series
data is very powerful and now I'm going
to turn it over to Misha he's going to
tell you how this actually can come to
life on GCP Thank You Brandon
so as we mentioned earlier Janice Graf
is an open-source scalable distributed
graph database it's an apache license
project it's it has is backed by the
Linux Foundation there are a number of
users and developers of this project now
it's quite popular and it's growing very
quickly javascript provides a variety of
support for different storage backends
as well as indexing backends and here
we're going to explore how to use Janice
graph with a BigTable backhand for
storage and elastic search for indexing
Bruyn alluded to this earlier so there's
a project code apache tinker pop and
tinker pop itself is also an apache
license the open source project and it
provides the framework for open source
graph modeling and computation and it is
hosted at the Apache Software Foundation
it also provides the gremlin query
language that is used for querying these
property graphs as Brian mentioned
Janice car supports the property graph
model and all the examples that you saw
our property graph models gremlin is
quite a popular acquiring language for
graphs and it's supported by over 15
popular graph databases here's an
example of deployment architecture of
how you can deploy a scalable graph
database on GCP so there's a solution
white paper that we've published at that
URL and what you'll see is that in that
solution Janus graph is running
containerized on gke together with
elastic search and Janus graph connects
to elastic for indexing and it's using
cloud BigTable as a storage back-end and
in front of it there's a load balancer
so you would run a number of different
Janus graph instances which themselves
are stateless and your applications
would talk to the load balancer and be
routed to one of the Janus craft
instances so what is cloud BigTable big
there was a sparse distributed
persistent multi-dimensional sorted map
as the description from the paper that
we published in 2006 let's dive into
some of the details behind what this is
so BigTable is a distributed key multi
value store so for a single key you can
store many different values pick tables
sparse and that if you don't write data
in particular a number of cells it does
not cost you any storage space so you
can store data in rows that is relevant
to them and you don't need
to fill out every single cell with no or
placeholder values BigTable supports
atomic operations so you can modify any
single set of values in a single row in
a single transaction and that will be
atomic BigTable provides a single index
which is the row key and the row keys
are stored in sorted order so you have a
sorted map here you see a stray ssin of
what a subset of a table would be in
BigTable and the various values here are
how you would address them so there are
column families and inside them are
column qualifiers and the way to address
a single cell is with the combination of
row column family and column qualifier
and that said the map actually also
includes a timestamp dimension so the
full mapping of values in BigTable is
with a row key a column which is a
combination of comma family and an
optional qualifier and a 64-bit
timestamp and the values in BigTable are
uninterpreted byte array so you can
store anything from JSON to protocol
buffers to snippets of audio or
thumbnails or anything that is relevant
to your particular use case every cell
in BigTable as I mentioned has an 764
attached to it so the way to think about
is is that big day was actually a three
dimensional database every cell can
store a number of different versions and
they do not have to match across the
different cells in the same row or a
different row so you can soar different
versions of the data which means you can
store time-series within these cells so
BigTable comes by default with
first-class support for time series and
you can also have an optional garbage
collection enabled for this so you can
keep writing data and older data will
automatically expire and be garbage
collected and removed for you let's talk
about a bit about how the requests are
routed in BigTable so clients connect to
a single end point which is a
combination of load balancing and proxy
layer two BigTable before they're routed
to BigTable server notes in the
following couple slides I will remove
the load balancing and proxy layer but
keep in mind that it is still there and
clients are not actually directly
connected BigTable notes which means
they don't need to do any discovery they
don't need to update anything based on
the membership of a given cluster
clients connected BigTable server knows
but BigTable itself is actually
stateless the data in BigTable was
actually stored in our distributed file
system which is Colossus which is the
successor to the Google file system and
here you can see the sections of data a
B C D and E which each of those is a
subset of a single BigTable table so
each one of those stores a sorted subset
of the keys in that table also note that
each pixel node owns a number of these
data regions and it has exclusive access
to them so this is what allows big table
to provide atomic updates within a
single row so an entire single row is
contained in exactly one of those
locations and exactly one BigTable
server node is responsible for managing
that data both from a read and write
perspective so now imagine we have one
of the server nodes is getting quite a
lot of activity from the clients because
it is managing a number of the popular
data sets its managing a B and C and so
it gets more traffic from the clients
than other other nodes what we can
easily do is just reassign the ownership
of the data from one node to another
note that there's no data motion taking
place because none of the nodes
themselves actually storing data locally
they provide support for caching but
there's no durable storage at the
BigTable node server level the data
stays in Colossus there's no movement
regardless of how many gigabytes or
terabytes you're storing and this
reassignment is very quick and the
clients don't even notice and again they
don't need to know that they need to
connect to a different server node
because they're required requests are
transparently routed to a different
server in response to BigTable behind
the scenes doing the optimization to
rebalance the data such that we provide
good performance regardless of the scale
now given that we're able to easily
reassign the node own the data ownership
from one node to another this means that
it's quite easy for us to scale the
cluster up and down by adding or
removing nodes to the cluster and from
the cluster because again there's no
data stored durably on a big table node
this means there are stateless and if
they're stateless we can easily move
them so the only thing that they store
is a cache of knowing what it is that
they're currently responsible for which
you know we can recently reassign so
this means also that a victim one node
be disappearing means
there's no data loss so BigTable has no
single point of failure here if you lose
a node there is no data loss that
because the data is replicated and
stored durably in Colossus because the
nose don't talk to each other in cloud
BigTable BigTable provides linear
scalability and performance as you add
notes to a BigTable cluster to make the
cluster larger you get linear
scalability in throughput and
performance because the nose don't do
any coordination because the
transactions only happen locally at a
single BigTable server node which means
also we can scale up and down without
any downtime again because of the
dynamic reassignment of the data from
one node to another behind the scenes
today we're really proud to announce
that we're launching replication to
general availability so this means that
within a BigTable instance you can
create more than one BigTable cluster
and when you write data once to a single
location it will be replicated
asynchronously to a different cluster a
single cluster provides strong
consistency in reason writes once you
switch to a multi cluster model it will
be eventually consistent across clusters
there are no manual steps that you need
to take to ensure data is replicated it
will be done for you automatically and
synchronized there are no repair steps
there are no management there's
literally nothing you need to do other
than to say please add another cluster
to this instance and the use case is
that this is quite applicable for our
both high availability serving for low
latency use cases as well as for
separating analytics from serving use
cases such that you don't impact your
serving traffic from large-scale
analytics and this is going to be GA as
of tomorrow July 25th it will increase
the SLA from ninety nine point five to
ninety nine nine five and there's zero
touch failover for high availability use
cases as I mentioned the BigTable data
model supports keys in sorted order and
then there is a bunch of cells that in
each row you can store data in so you
have cells and there's columns and
there's the data there is sorted by
column and so Janis graph the way it
stores a graph in BigTable is by styling
the vertices as the row keys in BigTable
and as Brian mentioned
there are properties on both the
vertices as well as the edges and so the
properties on the vertices as well as
the edges and the properties of the
edges are all stored within the row for
a single vertex this makes it really
easy and fast to find an arbitrary
vertex and then find the edges that are
outgoing from that vertex because
they're in the row and they're always
stored in that row together with the
vertex Brian also mentioned the
applicability of time series data to a
number of these use cases from IOT to
finance to supply chain open G's DB is a
very popular open source time series
database that stores millisecond
precision time series data and it scales
horizontally to support millions of
writes per second open T is DB chose a
particular schema to support on BigTable
and here you can see the row key itself
is quite complex that includes the
metric a timestamp and key value pairs
for the tags
note that in front of the row key they
added a salt this is to help distribute
the load such that if you have metrics
that maybe have similar keys that you
don't hotspot since we're keeping
everything in sorted order and then the
data is stored in the different cells of
the columns of that row so now you can
see that with the integrations that
BigTable provides for both time series
with open TS DB and graphs with Janis
graph we can support the use case that
the Brian spoke about earlier in the
different industries so BigTable
provides both of these types of use
cases a fully managed petabyte scale
database that scales linearly for
through for increased throughput while
also providing low latency because of
the sorted nature of keys and the ease
of finding the keys and it's great for
the time series and graph use cases that
we've discussed so let's talk about what
would it look like to deploy combined
architecture of both time series and
graph on GCP with BigTable so here you
have an example application that is
using both janus graph as well as open
th DB open g cv Janis graph and elastic
are all running containerized on
kubernetes they're both using BigTable
obviously each one of them will have a
separate data set and coded in a
different way so they can use different
tables but they can use the same
BigTable instance
we have an application that is providing
an API that is talking to Janis graph
and we have data coming in through pops
up that is being consumed by data flow
that is both publishing the time series
data to open keys DB as well as sending
requests to the API server here's an
example of how you would deploy open
kiss DB we have a similar solution as we
talked about earlier for Janis graph
there's also a simple way of deploying
open TSD be together with big table
using kubernetes on google cloud and
we've open sourced a home chart for
Janis graph that makes it really easy to
deploy Janis graph on kubernetes this is
open source and github and we all have
pointers at the end where you could find
it and our partners at XP row row this
container graph sample service that is
the application that I spoke about
earlier it's a drop wizard based demo
application it is also open source on
github and what it does is that it's
ingesting metrics that is the data that
is coming in to pub/sub and the
application that I spoke to your about
earlier that is the application that
they wrote that is the container graph
service that is contacted by dataflow
and that is talking to Janis graph and
what this application implements itself
is a graph API where you can add and
remove containers you can find upstream
and downstream services you can gather
the dependencies so you can do that
graph walk that by mentioned earlier if
something happens to a particular node
how can I find the upstream and
downstream dependencies what will be
affected and you can add and remove
containers so this architecture is both
a deployment architecture of what you
might deploy in Google cloud as well as
the graph that it will encode upon
deployment so it models itself as a
graph very meta so how would you connect
to Janis graph as we mentioned Janis
graph works with tinker pop and tinker
pop project provides a number of drivers
in the different languages and there are
project supported client libraries in
dotnet JavaScript Java and Python as
well as third party supported Scala
closure and go libraries when you write
queries in tinker pub and to think about
library the queries of themselves are
not text they're very fluent and they're
written to the language that you're
using so in this case in Java this is
what a query would look like so yet all
the benefit
of your IDE of the type checking system
rather than combining together or
concatenating strings and then sending
them to be processed by the server in
this case the query that we're showing
here is not very graph II it's not very
complicated this is just for
illustration purposes many of the
queries that you'll see in practice will
be more complicated and there'll be
quite a bit more to them in this case
the query that you'll see here this is
just retrieves a list of running
containers but there's much more you can
do with this a query in graph so this is
gremlin this is the graph query language
is actually called a traversal
internally it runs a state machine and
there are a bunch of steps to a
traversal and they will fall into one of
these five categories so when you see at
the bottom here you have G which is a
graph you will select vertices this is a
map phase you will filter to find a
specific vertex you will find out all
the outgoing edges by label and then you
select a particular attribute on the
outgoing edges so this will find you all
the names of all the people that are
known by that person in that first
segment so as you've seen you can use
both graph and time series databases to
solve a number of different problems in
a number of different industry verticals
this will give you both the micro view
as well as the map review of the
situation allow you to explore the data
at a high level through a graph and then
dive deep to understand what is the low
level behavior of the system at the
micro level using the time series and
janus graph and open tzv provide
scalable implementations off both the
graph and time series data models and
they can be both scaled as stateless
services on top of a scalable database
such as BigTable as next steps as ryan
and i mentioned there are a number of
resources that you can take a look at to
learn more about both everything that
we've talked about as well as find all
the demos that we mentioned so first
there's the cloud BigTable homepage
where you can learn more about BigTable
regarding janus graph the first link
there is a solution of how to run janice
craft with BigTable that is the
architecture that I showed earlier there
is the experiment inner graph project
that you'll find next and Jana scripted
org has a number of pointers to both our
users and use cases who is running it
how
running it what does it support what
language versions that you might want
you to use with it regarding gremlin the
graph query language there's an
excellent introduction to the gremlin
language by Calvin Lorenz that is the
first link there it's an entire book
it's open source it's also in github but
you can read it at this URL
it provides an in-depth tutorial that
you probably want to take a look at if
you're going to use a property graph you
want to learn gremlin and there's also a
learning program from our partners at
expiry that will also help you
understand a learn gremlin and become a
gremlin expert they're obviously also
forums and mailing lists where if you
have complicated questions you can ask
questions about gremlin and there's
Stack Overflow very very active users on
Stack Overflow core also developers of
the gremlin language regarding open T is
DB as I mentioned we have a solution
here of how to deploy open TCP on Google
Cloud with BigTable and there's also a
number of visualizations in the gallery
that experiment together that you might
want to take a look at
[Music]